he'd be hard-pressed to find a better
performance than what aaron nola did
last night against the washington
nationals well tonight we actually have
two candidates that could probably do
similar things as the nationals of the
phils get together for game three of a
four-game series jack wheeler 3-0 a 2.5
80 ra so overall hitting 355 11 home
runs 25 runs batted in
so overall hitting 355 11 home runs 25
runs batted in
sway gonna miss
99 again two outs here in the first
nothing over the center of the plate
everything running away from him at 97
to 99 miles an hour this last pitch
right here 99 up and away 21st career
start against the fields 24th on the
all-time strikeout list 2747.
one strike to mccutcheon
that one's out to left-center field
that'll be in for a base hit it's going
to split the gap and go all the way to
the wb mason side
mccutchen is at second base with his
fifth double of the year
struck bryce out twice walked him twice
there's the infield in harper one for
four against max
got him
93 cutting and diving a brilliant pitch
for max jersey's 56th strikeout he got
so many toys to play with right there he
could have went 97 up change up in the
third away he chose door number three
cut her under the hands
the strikeout number 27 48 in the career
of max scherzer
bruce is solo homer two for six in the
series
nice
similar to the pitch in which he struck
out harper so a long first for max but
he pitches around a lead off double a
walk with a couple of capes
and here is kurt suzuki he's hitting 11
straight
you know he threw it to the same spot
kind of handcuffed him almost
97 the previous pitch
went right back up there again great
location
on base streak 23 games
to the right side and sigour diving stop
has to hurry to his feet throws out
turner
that is a heck of a play
he had to get to his feet fast
and he did
bryce harper who struck out his first
at-bat against scherzer
and the change-up to strike him out
harper not a happy hitter
two fly balls in a k max has struck out
three tonight
here's kurt suzuki
swag of the miss he got the swing
through and a one two three fourth
inning for zach wheeler three strikeouts
tonight and a whole bunch of groundouts
good pitch and
rio muto into second base rather easily
a pretty good jump take the strike him
out and then you're looking for the
throw about but
because of the jump kurt suzuki had the
rush and the throw kind of sailed
all right so now you've got alec bowm
and a live drive out to left field
that's going to drop in for a base hit
soto's got it they put the stop sign on
that was a good decision by dustin yes
what a great swing by alec baum i mean
this kid like i said i i've never seen
him over mad
so left-handed on the year walker now
six for 20.
and he has eight career hits and 33 at
bats against scherzer
drive base hit it to left center field
one is in here comes segora he'll score
it's a broken bat
single for neal walker and the phillies
take a two-nothing lead
there's a pitch right there neal hits
off the end of the bat but you know they
have a shift on him there's no one there
luis garcia
can't even fit in there anymore like
most of america has how about balm
throws from his side and it's in time
what a play by alec bowm how about his
defense the last couple of nights adam
eaton now in a huge spot
did he go yes he did
that was an odd swing but he went around
five strikeouts
bruce will lead off for the phillies in
the bottom of the six with him
served out to left field going back out
of his soto back toward the wall it is
good
it carries right out out of the
solo
ballpark
run for jay bruce
is third against max scherzer and it's
three nothing bills
adventures of tommy hunter out in the
pool yep not having to look for any home
run balls just yet
at the top of the zone on the inner half
two outs here in the eighth inning
two down
a little tapper up the first base line
workman has it flips underhand in time
and the ball game is over five in a row
against the washington nationals as the
phil shut out the gnats for a second
consecutive night they do it tonight by
a final score of three nothing